Imran Khan is back home in Lahore
tasting Freedom after a dramatic arrest
by Pakistan's paramilitary
I mean I've watched this these guys
attacking suddenly these guys are bad
from somewhere over the sticks these
look like Commandos
and I thought you know they're here to
defend me because you know my life is a
threat so the the judge had ordered that
I have to be protected so I thought
they'd come to defend me and I thought
God looks like there's some terrorist in
the room and then I discovered it was me
the crafter so it was um shocking really
the way they beat up everyone and then
they took me like some sort of a
terrorist we're hearing from the
military and the government that the
security concerns around you and the
threat and risk has been so high that
this was the only option that you forced
their hand
they are petrified of Elections the gap
between us and all the other parties is
so huge now that they're petrified that
they will be wiped out so they have
decided that the only way they'll allow
elections is if I'm inside jail or
killed there are two attempts been two
attempts on me
and most of my senior leadership should
be jailed too this is what they've done
they've used this to put the entire
leadership of PTI in jail what is your
strategy if you are rearrested well no
strategy I'm mentally prepared to go
into jail your arrest
spread and violent
tests we
treat in installations
houses attacked government buildings do
you condemn that violence violence that
the governments say you're in supporters
carried out
I condemn I have always condemned all
violence
the tree has been the Bedrock of
case do you think you can run
the nation without the
Army because you run that risk of
alienating them not
evolve thinking changes we started off
as a security state
and had straight away martial law where
the Army ruled for 10 years but right
now I mean
I have never seen such oppression I mean
this total clampdown on media I can't
appear on live television if journalists
have picked up beaten up tortured
custodial torture of my senior members a
social media activist it's never
happened like this before do you have
faith in the Judiciary and where do you
think democracy in Pakistan is right now
well the Democracy in Pakistan has never
taken such a battering as it has right
now
I'm in all our fundamental rights are
violated this sort of thing has never
happened no political figure has ever
had 10 almost 50 cases and then his
house raided once they attacked for 24
hours then when I was away they threw an
armored car they broke through my door
raided my house my wife was all alone by
herself it's never happened before so
democracy is an all-time low the only
hope we have is the Judiciary
as the institutions battle it out the
people of Pakistan are suffering an
economy failing them progress threatened
by a paralyzing power struggle
Sky News Lahore Pakistan